Franchises are the backbone of Hollywood these
days, with every studio looking for ways to
plan out a series of tentpoles years in advance.
Often times, they’re working with a rich
mythology or decades of publication history
to draw from, so the stories write themselves.
Then there are the self-contained films that
don’t really leave anything open at the
end, calling into question why a follow-up
was ever produced.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 great movies that
never needed a sequel.
Jaws
Steven Spielberg’s thriller is one of the
most influential works of all-time, since
it introduced the concept of the studio blockbuster.
It became the first movie to gross $100 million
at the box office and set records, so the
studio wanted a sequel.
However, it wasn’t warranted.
Jaws ends with Brody killing the shark and
there isn’t anywhere else to go with the
concept or the characters.
Seeing that the sequels stretched the premise
to absurd lengths, the executives would be
been better suited following Spielberg’s
lead and leaving it after part one.
There are only so many times a shark can terrorize
the same beach… or family.
Rocky
We know what you’re thinking.
Without Rocky sequels, Creed would never be
possible, but it took a while for the champ
to regain his former glory.
The original is a hard-hitting sports drama
that’s the ultimate underdog tale and concludes
with Rocky rediscovering his self-value.
Over time, the series morphed into 1980s camp
with over-the-top villains, and essentially
disregarded Rocky’s heartfelt message.
In the first one, Balboa knew he couldn’t
beat Creed, but that didn’t really matter
in the end.
But every other time out, winning the final
fight was the ultimate goal.
And besides, Apollo said there wouldn’t
be a rematch and Rocky didn’t want one.
Jurassic Park
Imaginations were captured when dinosaurs
came back to life and moviegoers got to experience
the wonder of Jurassic Park.
But the severe consequences of the amusement
park were also placed front and center, illustrating
the dangers of bringing the prehistoric creatures
into the modern age.
After the experiment proved to be a disaster
the first time around, there’s really no
reason – other than box office dollars – to
keep going back to the well.
It’s a cautionary tale that plays out pretty
much the same way each time.
No matter how advanced your security measures
are, the dinosaurs will always rule the world.
The Hangover
Audiences were pleasantly surprised when the
first Hangover gave R-rated comedies a shot
in the arm and provided a zany collection
of laughs.
The cast was in top form, several of the jokes
landed, and a scary mystery fueled the plot
and gave it serious stakes.
Once Doug was found and the gang saw pictures
from the bachelor party, we were ready to
move on – but the Wolfpack wasn’t.
They came back for two more misadventures
that couldn’t live up to the original, mainly
because there was nothing new to bring to
the table.
Even Zach Galifianakis says the sequels were
disappointing, so let’s just consider the
first one canon.
Die Hard
Arguably the perfect action movie, Die Hard
is a tour de force with thrilling set pieces,
a great hero, and an even better villain.
It also tied everything up nicely at the end,
as John McClane reconnected with his wife
and rode off to celebrate the holidays with
his family.
There didn’t seem to be room for another
story, but sequels were made.
Sure, the follow-ups have their moments of
fun and entertainment, but none of them can
hold a candle to what made the original so
special.
When moviegoers think of John McClane, they
think of the first film, and there’s a good
reason for that.
Speed
One of the best action films of the 1990s,
Speed was a white-knuckled ride from start
to finish, keeping viewers on the edge of
their seats with excitement and well-rendered
characters.
Like so many movies of its kind, Speed probably
would have been better served as a one-and-done
exercise.
One only has to look at Speed 2 for proof,
since it’s one of the more underwhelming
action flicks ever released.
Featuring thin characterization and set pieces
that bored rather than thrilled, it was clear
it didn’t have anything to add and almost
ruined what came before.
If they couldn’t get Keanu Reeves back,
they probably should have left it alone.
Monsters, Inc.
Pixar’s 2001 hit is one of their most inventive
and beloved, featuring creative world building
and wonderful characters that touched the
heart.
The story it told was so perfect, the studio
couldn’t move forward with a second installment
– they had to go back in time.
A prequel, Monsters University, showed how
Mike and Sully met in college and became the
lifelong friends we see in the original.
While it was fun to see the monsters back
in action and another side of the universe,
it’s seen as second-rate Pixar that isn’t
as effective as the first film.
Moviegoers would have preferred Pixar make
an original concept than go back to a well
they’ve hit before.
Men in Black
It’s a premise that’s seemingly set up
for sequels, but Men in Black should have
been left alone.
The filmmakers weren’t entirely sure how
to handle a follow-up, and brought back Tommy
Lee Jones to work with Will Smith.
Unfortunately, this undermines the emotional
conclusion of the first film, where Agent
Kay steps down to have his memory wiped so
he can reunite with his true love.
His story should have ended there, especially
since Men in Black II could only recycle elements
from the first movie and didn’t feel as
fresh.
When there’s nowhere to go with the characters,
it’s best to leave it untouched.
Grease
One of the most memorable musicals ever, the
original Grease is full of catchy tunes, fun
characters, and an entertaining story about
young love.
Since it was so popular, the studio tried
to force a sequel, and the results were not
nearly as impressive.
While Grease 2 did have solid song and dance
numbers of its own, it was dismissed largely
as a retread of the first one – with a new
cast - that didn’t really bring anything
new to the table.
Fans could just watch the original and get
all the summer loving they needed.
Caddyshack
An endlessly quotable comedy with hilarious
characters and situations, 1980’s Caddyshack
is seen as one of the high points of the genre
and a favorite for moviegoers everywhere.
Released 8 years later, the sequel became
Exhibit A for why comedy follow-ups are a
bad idea.
It surprisingly went for a family-friendly
PG rating, and was handicapped by a lackluster
script that didn’t provide many laughs.
It was probably a bad sign that Chevy Chase
was the only original cast member that signed
on to return; the rest uninterested or concerned
it wouldn’t be good.
The filmmakers should have listened to Bill
Murray.
Those are our picks for great films that never
needed a sequel.
Are there any we missed?
Which movies do you wish stayed standalone?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!